et là c'était
ça y est vous voilà et bien bonjour je
vous attendais pour continuer à voir une
telle histoire que j'avais commencé hier
vous souvenez nous étions en lan créé
146 juste au début de la guerre de cent
ans qui avait très mal commencé pour les
français battus par les anglais à la
bataille de crécy
juste après cette bataille roi
d'angleterre edouard iii avait envoyé
ici dans l'île aux enfants
deux de ses meilleurs généraux le 4 nov
du snob et le général khan tri pour
prendre possession de nos enfants
les deux généraux on sent que lille
était très bien défendu avait préféré
accepter un traité qui leur donnerait
l'île aux enfants à la mort du prince
casini russe et à la condition que la
guerre durera moins de 100 en personne
alors quand j'en ai entendu parler d'une
guerre qui dure à moins de cent ans et
le prince ghazi mirus leur semblait très
très vieux et depuis ce jour tandis que
les français les anglais continuer de se
battre
l'île aux enfants vivaient
tranquillement loin des bruits de la
guerre et son prince casimir us était
toujours bien en vie
mais un jour de l'an treize 179
c'est à dire 33 ans plus tard
comment faire un champ de courses pour
les autres achats sans abîmer le champ
de carottes de la page c'est difficile
ça le chevalier of death note b le
général country demande d'audience
bien qu'ils en feront bon seigneur
monseigneur comment allez vous il ya
longtemps que nous sommes ne naissent
pas canton je crois qu'il ne s'agissait
pas de nous mais de nos pains le code
c'est fou comme le temps passe vite pas
pour tout le monde
nous étions venus prendre possession d'
or il nous pensions que vous étiez mort
je suis vraiment désolée pour elle nous
sommes donc venus quand la possession de
l'île le plus rapidement possible pareil
c'est parfaitement exact l'honneur de
l'angleterre aux dépens - bien sûr à
étant donné qu'en du guesclin vient
d'infliger quelques défaites aux anglais
vous souhaité redorer votre blason faut
se voit que vous connaissez parfaitement
notre problème nous allons vous demander
la permission de vous laisser envahir
c'est impossible avait pourquoi un petit
qu'ils font non que nous ne ferons que
de petits matins
non non et non monseigneur monseigneur
écoutez moi j'ai entendu des voix me
dire d'aller sauver la france
enfin que tu arrive trop tard du déclin
est déjà en train de le faire et que je
dis déjà à ta mère il ya content de ne
pas s'occuper des affaires de la guerre
elle a raconté il était là taisez vous
c'est toujours pareil si on ne croit pas
j'en ai assez
voilà voilà vous l'avez vexée elle est
furieuse maintenant au garde mon
seigneur seigneur a besoin de moi cela
ans comme moi ces deux imbéciles dans
leur bateau et qu'il disparaisse vous
allez ouste d'accord poule
non mais ça râle on est de nouveau
l'îlot z'enfants vécu à l'écart de la
guerre